and you never sleep and I think like if
women were valued in the feminine like
the typical female roles then maybe like
life would be better because I would
love to be a housewife yeah it's just it
feels like it's not even a it's not even
a option anymore
economically like with the first guy
could you have been
um
no not no because like we'd like I don't
know I don't know how much money because
engineer whatever but like I wouldn't
have been able to be just a whole like a
housewife like economically that's just
not viable anymore unless you're dating
like millionaires billionaires well you
know what's crazy my friends I have a
really good friend that's a housewife
and she she won't like she was trending
on Twitter for just saying that she was
a housewife and she served she loves her
husband she serves him he's the boss and
like it's crazy to me that that's so
much backlash foreign
important well that's where it goes back
to statistics about a nuclear family
right that I read in the beginning of
the show because having that nuclear
family is essential for societies to
function
um I I think the society is a little bit
dis well a lot dysfunctional because of
the lack of nuclear family structure
yeah and you know I would also argue
that it is possible as a woman I guess
to find a guy who's able to look after
you and your kids so you don't have to
work but the reality is you need to be
strategic about how you're going to
actually get that guy to commit to you
you need to provide value in certain
ways and a lot of women like and I'm not
saying this is good or bad it's just
they need to understand all the
consequences of this belief is going to
be right you need to understand if you
believe that a guy who has a lot of
options should just choose you why
because you're you then the result of
that is not going to be you know
amicable for you right that's the
reality so you need to realize that what
women need to realize that if you're
going to keep a guy who has a lot of
options you need to provide a lot of
tangible value apart from just whatever
you can do in a sexual domain well but
also also
um in Reverse to that
um if a man wants a woman of a caliber
or a certain caliber he has to provide
hundreds so many different things as in
like wealth he has to be the type of man
she would admire look up to in any way
shape or form he has to behave in a
certain manner for her to even like
somewhat respect him or feel comfortable
just
essentially relinquishing certain powers
of course I mean sorry go on yeah well
everything a woman does in a
relationship is for her happiness
everything Amanda is does in a
relationship is for a woman's happiness
generally a woman does things in a
relationship so she can be happy right
and then the man does things in a
happy wife happy life right so we get
that term happy wife happy life and so
what happens is all of this attention is
just thrown upon the woman it's all
about her happiness all about her
happiness all about you keeping her open
happy and a man goes out generally he
goes out to work
brings home the bacon yeah and he's got
to protect this whole structure he's got
to protect her happiness make sure she's
happy and then keep her happy all the
while negating his own generally he
negates his own happiness to keep the
woman happy
do you get what I'm saying wouldn't you
agree then that the issue is more that
we should fulfill our own happiness
instead of relying on our partners to
fulfill that for us and that will shift
the dynamic of being like having that
dependence and so if a woman has that
independent energy which is able to look
after herself she's able to attract a
man who can look after himself and
together they can probably look after a
child because they're not searching for
their happiness in each other so
wouldn't you say that's more the issue I
think yeah I think people should fulfill
themselves within whatever happiness
whatever makes them happening yeah I
don't think life's about happiness it's
about fulfillment and I think and I
think women over a certain age are not
fulfilled if they don't have a husband
and a family like what are you going to
do at 60 by yourself you have a job you
have a job that could fire you tomorrow
do you think that's because we've been
taught that that's what fulfills us
especially in terms of that nuclear
family
so to answer your question to answer
your question no I think it's biology I
think you can't undo biology but I think
even biology to an extent is taught
because it's evolved it's evolved from
what we practice over and over and over
again right so that's still generational
to me that's still taught that goes back
that Dynamic goes back years but it
doesn't mean necessarily that it's the
most healthy Dynamic yeah
for thousands of years not you know
social constructs change every what a
couple hundred years biology is like
well scientists estimates 300 000 years
that human beings have been alive 300
000 years of evolutionary biology that's
not really a that's a very formidable
opponent that you don't really want to
be going against it's less like in the
past than that I mean the rules the
rules of kind of like more in like
sophisticated Society we live in this
Society where that role is a bit more
structured it's a bit more defined than
it was previously where the woman was um
the nurture at the forager you know she
had an active role in society she was
just important as the man she was seen
as an equal because they had equal roles
instead of the man being this power when
sorry sorry when
um I couldn't give you a specific
demographic because I think I think for
like sophisticated societies not
develops even like medieval stages
it was I'm saying I don't think it was
ever equal because men always had to
protect women but that doesn't mean that
the woman's um position is less valid
it's valued it's valuable in a different
I'm saying they did different things
exactly but I I like no one's talking
about what's more valuable or what's
less but both are valuable yeah yeah
yeah nobody's saying women like what
they do isn't valuable what we're saying
is men and women are different right and
you can't and you can't undo biology and
I don't know why you would want to
change something that's worked for
thousands and thousands of years so it's
like don't you think it's a bit arrogant
to come in and don't you think it's a
bit arrogant to come in and say you know
better than like thousands of years of
people I think it's more the rigidity
I'm talking about the rigidity of the
rules that we are expected to be in a
certain way but to me so so to me like I
I've always been told I can do anything
and I could be like I could start a
business I could do what I want I've
never been pushed into roles and if
anything I've seen more backlash for
women that go into traditional roles
than women that act more modern so I I
don't think society's really pushing
women to be traditional anymore and
that's I definitely agree with that
because it is pushing women to be more
professional because in capitalism where
your value comes from
not by everyone but people see you in a
higher status if you earn more money you
earn no money looking after children
unless you're a nanny and when you look
at the salary of anani compared to a
banker you know
it's not it's and that's why women feel
like they need to go off and like
succeed and become a valuable member of
society because they don't feel like
having a baby is enough to be valued
which is so depressing but why does it
shouldn't it shouldn't it only matter if
your husband values you who cares what
Society thinks everyone that's like
humans care what other humans think like
that's like how to stay in in a society
to not get kicked out of one to die
you actually care what other people
think and you want to make sure that
everything yeah but you need to pick the
people whose opinions you actually value
right you can't just value everyone's
opinions because at the end of the day
people people's lives their lifestyle is
a reflection of the opinions that they
have so if you don't want this person's
lifestyle in future then you really
shouldn't be internalizing their
opinions because you will be doing
yourself a massive decision which is
difficult there's a certain level of
Consciousness that requires that as well
which is like an incredibly privileged
space to be in because if you are living
in survival mode effectively which a lot
of people are then you don't have the
conscious mind is to make those
decisions you're going to keep falling
into those survival patterns because you
can't physically step out of that you
don't have the choice to and because of
different systemic pressures so many
different factors contributing to that I
just have no idea what you just said
I mean I would argue from personal
experiences that's in great like when I
left him when I was 17 and it was all
about survival I really couldn't care
less what anyone thought about me the
only people whose opinions I cared about
were people who are the lifestyle I
wanted to have in the future and and
that was it like if you don't have the
lifestyle I want in three to five years
or you know the the results you have in
this particular field of discussion
isn't desirable to me then I have no
choice but to disregard your opinion
because I'll be doing myself a massive
disservice ultimately but it's such a
privilege to have um it's a privilege to
know people that you want to be like not
everyone is in a it's in like a
community where they can look up to
someone who is a positive influence of
what you want to be and like I get when
you're an adult you've got a choice
where you live but at the end of when
you're growing up up like you only know
what you know yeah but it became that
influence for myself do you think it's a
privilege to be born in 2022 where
you're richer than most people even the
richest people were in all of human
history so even like poor people today
are richer than people were in most of
History you never know because you don't
know what it's going to be like in 20
years no no but we know but we know
what's going on the last like four
thousand yeah and so so you could say
being born in 2022 is much better than
being bored during the plague
perspective right because like if
anything everybody's privileged in 2022.
I think one of the reasons why people
are the most depressed in these days and
times because we take the most
antidepressants we're the most anxious
we're the most depressed in the west is
because we have put we have put
expectations upon ourselves right which
are basically unrealistic and so we get
upset and you know we get depressed by
the fact that we can't actually reach
those expectations whereas you know if
you go back
to the 60s 50s 40s people were happier
because people talk about especially
when it comes to women right people talk
about oh women had to they never had any
rights and they had to you know ask men
for everything they were happier they
want less antidepressants they were less
anxious they would they were less there
was less anxiety there were there were
less mental illnesses in in the DSM yes
but that's because feminine mental
illness was defined as hysteria and
women were sent to like get you know
electrost therapy because they were
emotional and that's any kind of mental
illness was defined as that it's not
because it wasn't present it's because
we didn't have the words
instances of that a lot to you to use it
as the general rule is a misnomer there
were a lot more than instances of it
that was the majority of women who
expressed any sort of emotionality
beyond the point of what was expected
were defined as having hysteria and
we're required or a witch burned at the
stage
you're not going back to like 17 like no